uh anything else you working on or
anything else you want to talk about man
uh [__] I'm working on my clothing line
my f cancer clothing line yeah I'm
trying to set up something with my album
where uh percentage of the proceeds that
I make could go towards like a cancer uh
organization make sure it's like one
that like I feel like some of the bigger
ones are so much bureaucracy wrapped up
in like where the money goes like lot
yeah you always got to worry about that
but it's coming from a genuine place for
me no that's amazing feel me so yeah uh
yeah my clothing line that should be out
like around when my album come out
trying to set up everything uh [__] just
be ready for my album it's going to be
16 songs 12 of them going to be brand
new a lot of hot features uh a lot of
styles that y'all never heard from me
before uh [__] not to end the interview
on a somber note but obviously the you
know you losing your dad to cancer is a
big deal to you you big deal to anybody
uh for you what would be some advice if
someone lost a parent um what would be
the advice you would give to them how to
cope how to mourn how to get through it
how to get on the other side of it you
know uh well first let me explain to you
how it even happened first so pretty
much uh 2016 I was working at FedEx used
to work at the warehouse at
LAX and um you know when he first got
diagnosed with it that [__] hurt you
feel me but he was taking all the
precautions to get rid of it like
everything I'm talking to a tea Cho
everything wake up at this time take
this you feel me coffee enas salads like
everything everything so um he got rid
of it uh he got rid of the pancreatic
cancer and he got rid of it for about
two months then he came to my house one
day he was like uh came back to his
liver though so I'm like damn here this
go again
so after that
happened I'm working I'm working you
know he's still doing his [__] he C my
mom came to my job at FedEx my mom don't
go
nowhere like she literally don't leave
the house so when my manager like my mom
here I'm like what the [__] I'll rush to
the front she like oh they gave him two
months I'm like wow damn yeah that [__]
hit different I left the job you feel me
crying all type of [__] and then uh
after that that day it was about two
weeks was about two weeks uh my stepmom
wind up calling me from the hospital she
like yeah it's that time so I Rush up
there when I got there he taken like
like a breath like every 45 seconds or
30 seconds barely hanging on barely
hanging on so what a lot of people don't
know is I actually got to see my dad
take his last breath wow yeah like
literally the last one whole family
standing over him like trying to touch
him a little bit like make sure he stay
up and once he took that last one he was
out so that right there like seeing that
was so detrimental to me that's what
sparked like me to even do music you
feel me so me like blowing up and even
being able to sit right here with you is
like like whoa It's like a real
Testament to my journey like I can't
even believe I'm here you're lucky to
have been there with him no definitely
right cuz you cuz I I had it both ways
when my so my grandpa when he passed
away I was holding his hand oh wow yeah
and I was it was me and my cousin in the
room with him MH cuz he was in hospice
and they and they knew he was going to
die so they brought him back to my my
family's house so I was holding his hand
literally while he died yeah so I felt I
don't want to say I felt good about it
but I felt like at peace with it yeah
during covid my grandma died of Co in a
nursing home and they wouldn't let us be
with her because of Co so she died alone
that's [__] up that [__] [__] me up
cuz you're like damn like we wanted to
be there but this Co [__] [__] right
they wouldn't let anybody in the nursing
home so my grandma passed away by
herself we don't know what she was
thinking we don't know nothing you know
what I'm saying rest in PE you're lucky
to have been with your been there for
sure for sure I don't take that for
granted that that moment just like
that's like a real you know that I hold
that [__] right here like n that's dope
it's a part of your mission now
definitely but as far as advice I would
say
um if you Lo lost anyone you feel me for
anybody that lost someone find something
to not take your mind off of it cuz
nothing take your mind pour the pain
into something into something that's
exactly something productive for sure
something productive cuz you could pour
it into something negative exactly you
know [__] 100% pour it in something
positive you feel me find something if
it's going to the gym whatever you feel
me find something that's going to fuel
you and like make you put on for your
person you lost well you done a good job
man appreciate you salute on the success
um I look forward to hearing the album
and you got a name for the
album king of Ratchet King of Ratchet
yeah that's what we've been missing in
La y'all yeah back to the ratchet [__]
we going to stamp that
yeah you're going to make Joe Moses and
Y and everybody proud I got oh hell yeah
and I I'll be doing shows with Joe Moses
and all that we got a show on March 4th
n Joe's the greatest he's such a nice
guy and he like a real OG and he got a
hot record right
now he's got a joint crazy as [__] Joe's
good for like every 3 or four years just
a joint bounce out with something crazy
for sure shout out to and that remix on
the way too there it oh [__] there it is
man L vad I appreciate you pulling up
brother sir appreciate you for having me